[Music]
out of this tumult spirit would be
thrown back to its starting point to the
ethical and real world of culture which
would have been merely refreshed and
rejuvenated by the fear of the Lord and
Master which has again entered men's
hearts spirit would have to traverse
anew and continually repeat this cycle
of necessity if the result were only the
complete interpenetration of self
consciousness and substance and
interpenetration in which self
consciousness which has experienced the
negative power of its universal essence
acting on it would desire to know and
find itself not as this particular
individual but only as a universal and
therefore to would be able to endure the
objective reality of a universal spirit
a reality excluding self consciousness
qua particular but in absolute freedom
there was no reciprocal action between a
consciousness that is immersed in the
complexities of existence or that sets
itself specific aims and thoughts and a
valid external world whether of reality
or thought instead the world was
absolutely in the form of consciousness
as a universal will and equally self
consciousness was drawn together out of
the whole expanse of existence or
manifested aims and judgments and
concentrated into the simple self the
culture to which it attains in
interaction with that essence is
therefore the grandest and the last is
that of seeing its pure simple reality
immediately vanish and pass away into
empty nothingness in the world of
culture itself it does not get as far as
to behold its negation or alienation in
this form of pure abstraction on the
contrary its negation is filled with a
content either honor or wealth which it
gains in place of the self that is
alienated from itself or the language of
spirit and insight which the disrupted
consciousness acquires or it is the
heaven of faith or the utility of the
Enlightenment all these determinations
have vanished in the loss suffered by
the self in absolute freedom its
negation is the death that is without
meaning the sheer terror of the negative
that contains nothing pause
nothing that fills it with a content at
the same time however this negation in
its real existence is not something
alien it is neither the universal
inaccessible necessity in which the
ethical world perishes nor the
particular accident of private
possession nor the whim of the owner on
which the disrupted consciousness sees
itself dependent on the contrary it is
the universal will which in this its
ultimate abstraction has nothing
positive and therefore it can give
nothing in return
for the sacrifice but for that very
reason it is immediately one with self
consciousness or it is the pure positive
because it is the pure negative and the
meaningless death the unfulfilled
negativity of the self changes round in
its inner notion into absolute
positivity for consciousness the
immediate unity of itself with the
universal will its demand to know itself
as the specific point in the universal
will is changed round into the
absolutely opposite experience what
vanishes for it in that experience as
abstract being or the immediacy of that
insubstantial point and this vanished
immediacy is the universal will itself
which it now knows itself to be insofar
as it is a peer knowing or pure will
consequently it knows that will to be
itself and knows itself to be essential
being but not essential being as an
immediate existence not will as
revolutionary government or Anarchy
striving to establish anarchy nor itself
as the center of this faction or the
opposite faction on the contrary the
universal will is it's pure knowing and
willing and it is the universal will qua
this pure knowing and willing it does
not lose itself in that will for pure
knowing and willing is much more it than
is that atomic point of consciousness it
is thus the interaction appear knowing
with itself pure knowing qua essential
being is the universal will but this
essential being is absolutely nothing
else but pure knowing self consciousness
is therefore the pure knowing of
essential
being qua your knowing further as an
individual self it is only the form of
the subject or of real action a form
which is known by it as form similarly
objective reality being is for it simply
a selfless form for that reality would
be something that is not known this
knowing however knows knowing to be
essential being
paragraph 594 is the second to last
paragraph in this section it's very long
there's a lot going on in there it
probably could have been split up into
multiple paragraphs but but instead
Hegel brings all of this material
together in a sort of culmination very
much like what a composer might do in
bringing things to a kind of crescendo
whether we're talking about classical
music or we're thinking about various
forms of rock music I'm not really
complicated to talk about other genres
of music in that respect and and what's
going on here Hegel is really doing two
main things one is drawing this this
contrast between the development that
took place in consciousness in this
transition to what he's calling the the
grandest and last culture that of the
the absolute freedom and the terror and
where we're going from there something
has happened to self consciousness
something new that we didn't see in the
previous shapes of self-consciousness
developed in the earlier dynamics in the
the culture section and then in the
faith and enlightenment discussions that
were taking place that's one thing
that's going on the other thing that's
going on is he's preparing our
transition to the next big section of
Spirit the last section of spirit which
is morality moral consciousness and you
might say well that's been there the
whole time
the term moral or we'll talk much more
about this later when we get into it
he's using that for a specific reason as
opposed to ethical and there's a kind of
universality involved there that is it
took an achievement on human beings
parts to get us there that's part of
this last and grandest culture that he's
referring to so a lot of material let's
look at the text itself see what Hegel
has the same out of this Humboldt what's
the tumult the reversion
back into the sphere the spiritual
masses and spheres in absolute freedom
he says spirit would be thrown back to
its starting point so we would have this
cyclical transformation here I want to
say something a little bit about the
development within the the phenomenology
of spirit and in Hegelian philosophy
more generally that I think often gets
left out in part because you know we're
really looking at a story that's being
told about the development of human
consciousness over time but we're only
looking at certain representative places
and times where it's developing further
so what we're leaving out is the fact
that in most places in times things are
proceeding in a cyclical manner so you
know the French Revolution happens and
that's happening in France and it's
going to spill over into the rest of the
continent of course something different
is going on in America but that's also
influenced by it as well and what's
happening in other places what's
happening in in Spain what's happening
in North Africa what's happening in the
Egypt that Napoleon you know and
conquered and get booted out of it's not
the same thing the the the older
dynamics remained in place churning away
there so spirit develops for Hegel in
particular places and times cultures and
individuals and it is quite possible for
you to have what he's just calling here
you know spirit being thrown back to its
starting points
and what is its starting point in this
section the ethical and real world of
culture and he says there would have
been something gained in the process
being refreshed and rejuvenated by the
fear of the lord and master which is
again entered men's hearts we see
something like this all the time when we
witness calls for cultural renewal that
are based on like raising the stakes you
know if we just had a good war that
would like live in everything up and
shake things and
and get people to be men again you know
that this is a theme that gets said over
and over and over again by the way Hagel
himself can sometimes say things like
that for example in his reason in
history but here that's not what's going
on Hagel is not suggesting that we
should simply you know go back to
business as usual now is a little bit
more liveliness involved because we
tasted the fear of death but didn't die
in the process no we need something
different instead he said spirits if
that was the case would have to go
through this entire dynamic once again
it would have to as he says traverse
anew and continually repeat this cycle
of necessity if something was the case
now what's the key differentiating
factor here that's what he's going to
tell us here's how he expresses it if
the result were only the complete
interpenetration of self-consciousness
and substance very metaphysical way of
talking right what is he what is he on
about there well the substance is the
you might say ways in which society is
organized understood and ruled
self-consciousness is the the individual
the person persons of course because
it's plural we're never abstractly just
talking about one person in a
solipsistic way as being you know the
one person in relation to society but we
you know we can think of this writ large
you might say so he says this is an
inter penetration in which
self-consciousness which experience the
negative power of its universal essence
acting on it would desire to know and
find itself not as this particular
individual but only as a universal so
what Hegel is saying happened in the
previous developments of
self-consciousness is there some kind of
universal something beyond the
individual and the individual tries to
find him or herself in relation to that
perhaps even by a you know sir
eugen or you know completely a basing
itself before that the the obedience of
the previous shapes of
self-consciousness could fit in there
this is not going to be something
available in the absolute freedom and
terror development so he goes on and he
says this would enable it to endure the
objective reality of universal spirit a
reality excluding self-consciousness qua
particular in the earlier shapes insofar
as you were just a particular you were
in essence the fly in the ointment or
you know not to put too fine a point on
it
evil busy the bad right we had the noble
self-consciousness and then we have the
base self-consciousness which of course
turned out to be the one who truly had
the advantage and we saw this
development in earlier sections as well
think about virtue in the way of the
world right the law of the heart and the
frenzy of self conceit even pleasure
didn't work like that pleasure led into
death so he says there's something
different going on here what is it in
absolute freedom for the first time
there was no as he says reciprocal
action between a consciousness immersed
in the complexities of existence losing
itself within the complexities of the
socialized world or its activities or
any of those sorts of things or that
sets itself specific aims and thoughts
right specific goals vodka and and
things to consider think about the
reason section and so all of that is on
one side and a valid external world a
world that you're part of but which is
different from you
whether he says of reality or a thought
so this this can be and what does he
mean by valid
I mean you know true in the sense of I
we finally hit the you know the bedrock
of everything know you know working for
you at the time part of your realm of
experience allowing you to make sense
out of things so now he's going to give
us some examples of this right
first though he tells us the culture oh
here we go
instead the world was absolutely in the
form of consciousness as a universal
will this is how what we've just
traversed is different and equally self
consciousness was drawn together out of
the whole expanse of existence or
manifested aims and judgments
concentrated into a single self so the
stakes have been raised in a unique way
in absolute freedom in the terror every
self consciousness could see itself in
that Universal will how do you know that
something at is actually the universal
will you as a rational self
consciousness can come to grasp it
whether you're some illiterate peasant
you can be brought to literacy and
educated about you know the social
policy and what's rational or whether
you're some legislature you know whether
you're belonging to a privileged class
who now is being if to recognize that as
privileges are arbitrary and should give
them up or whether you're part of the
rising bourgeoisie who you know view
themselves is becoming the essential
class something different has happened
here the world that was opposed to one
is on the one hand interpenetrated by
you as the individual and on the other
hand it's composed of other individuals
and you can ask why does that guy get to
run the show
why not me I'm just as rational as he is
I'm just as free isn't that what you
know freedom equality and fraternity
ought to mean we all take turns running
the show why are you in charge
Robespierre why are you in charge why a
committee right so something has changed
here he says
self-consciousness is drawn together out
of this whole expanse of existence or
manifested aims and judgments
concentrated into a single self and that
single self ends up being the one that
runs the show all right so the culture
to which it attains an interaction with
that essence is therefore the grandest
in the last last not necessarily in the
sense of we never have any culture after
that but it's another way of translating
last year that's the would be the latest
it is the latest on the scene right
grandest ear haben stuff all right so he
goes on and he says it's that of seeing
it's pure simple reality immediately
vanish and pass away into empty
nothingness Hegel is not using the word
nihilism here right that's that's a
later concept but this is something that
is coming on the scene in a way
different from the other places where
we've pointed it out in say the culture
section there is a nothingness a
negativity inhabiting the entire social
fabric ready to pop out at any moment
that can take determinate form as
suspicion as terror as death which
itself is a negativity or nothingness
right so he says in the world of culture
itself that the previous dynamics it
does not get what's it self
consciousness it does not get as far as
to behold it's negation or alienation in
this form of pure abstraction Hegel says
a pure abstraction that can be on the
other hand very concrete my concern in
my very core about my death so he goes
that I says on the contrary negation is
filled with the content now what is he
talking about there some sort of
universal that we frame ourselves in
relation to what are the contents that
were available in preview
dynamics and the shapes of consciousness
that went along with them
he says it's you know in culture right
it's filled with either honor or wealth
which it gains in place of the self that
it is alienated from itself so honor in
terms of state power the the obedient
serving noble consciousness is honored
in the process it loses some of who it
is and it gains a universal in relation
to that wealth is a universal as well as
we discovered and the base self
consciousness may arrange itself in
relation to that as the one who starts
to gain wealth and then can you know
attain a different sort of consciousness
both both types of consciousness you
have to frame themselves in relation to
wealth because you need it to get things
done and can be bought out by that and
then he goes on and he says or the
language of spirit and insight which the
disrupted consciousness acquires the the
the I don't have that here on the board
but that's the one that who falls
through the cracks the you know nephew
of ROM Oh indeed arose story the person
who is ironic the person who can't find
a place to fit into the culture and yet
can't escape the culture either and then
we move on to the world of pure thought
right the world as understood through
pure thought and he says or it is the
heaven of faith having in some
determinate form whether it be
understood in terms of the heaven as
conceived by you know various Christian
thinkers or you know by Muslims or you
know all sorts of other conceptions
available in terms of faith of course
here in Europe and in the development of
the consciousness that's leading to the
French Revolution we're talking about
Christianity many different conceptions
of heaven all you got to do is read
through some of the literature of the
time and where people are trying to
describe it you get the basis forms of
sort of sensual self-gratification
all the way to the most sublime
understandings of Concorde love and you
know sort of a almost reflection of love
into itself encompassing all individuals
say and Anselm of Canterbury so he goes
on and he says or the utility of the
Enlightenment now what's the upshot here
says all of these determinations all of
these things that we can orient
ourselves towards as values as things
that could arrange our life meaningfully
our aims our actions our relations with
other people he says all of these have
vanished in the loss suffered by the
self in absolute freedom absolute
freedom working itself out realising
itself is more of a loss than a gain
with respect to everything else that
came before it so what has been gained
then he says it's negation the negation
of absolute freedom is the death without
meaning the sheer terror of the negative
that contains nothing positive nothing
that fills it with a content it has had
the effect not just a sort of wiping the
slate clean but of shattering the slate
and putting nothing else in its place
and urging the self consciousness to at
the same time find something else that's
going to be put in its place this is a
significant problem is it not so he says
the ethical world you know it's neither
the universal inaccessible necessity in
which the ethical world perishes nor the
particular accident of private
possession nor the whim of the owner on
which the disrupted consciousness sees
itself dependent on the contrary what is
absolute freedom it is the universal
will which in its ultimate abstraction
as nothing positive and can give nothing
for the sacrifice in all the previous
forms of consciousness you set you
alienated yourself you sacrifice
something of yourself
and got something else in the process
and tried to pretend like that was you
know fulfillment here you're all you're
still alienating you're still
sacrificing and you're getting a big bag
of nothing except death as your payoff
now you might say well that sounds
terrible what the hell kind of culture
is that right purely nihilistic if we
want to think about it that way now
here's where Hegel tells us there's an
important game for that very reason he
says it's immediately won with soft
consciousness because it's the pure
negative it's also the pure positive and
the meaningless death he says the
Unified Field negativity of the self
changes around in its inner notion into
absolute positivity something new comes
on the scene so he says the immediate
unity of consciousness with the
universal will its demand this is the
beautiful way of place framing it to
know itself as this specific point in
the universal will is change it around
into the exact opposite experience what
vanishes for it is it's abstract being
or the immediacy of that insubstantial
point and this vanished immediacy is the
universal will itself which now it knows
self-consciousness individual
self-consciousness knows itself to be
insofar as it is a peer knowing or pure
will I as this guy here and just as much
a center of the ethical universe the
intellectual universe as any one of
those other poor bastards out there or
whoever is in charge and who can
threaten me with death all of us are in
a certain respect by participating in
this culture placed or rather elevated
to a higher plane this is the again that
last and and grandest culture so he goes
on and he says
consequently it knows that will what
will the general the universal will it
knows that to be itself and knows itself
to be essential being but not essential
being as an immediate existence and now
notice what else Hegel's ruling out here
not will is revolutionary government or
Anarchy striving to establish anarchy
nor itself as the center of this faction
or the opposite faction all this
struggles that are going on these
determinate struggles within the
revolutionary sphere on the contrary
says this Universal will is pure knowing
and pure will right he says this
universal will is pure knowing and
willing it is the universal will qua
this knowing and willing this is going
to transition us to the realm of what
Hegel is calling morality out of the
ethical sphere and to the moral sphere
notice what else he says it does not
lose itself in this will in the previous
dynamics of spirit you kind of had to
lose yourself in wealth or God or you
know utility or whatever it happened to
be here you get to keep yourself so he
goes on and he says it does not lose
itself for pure knowing and willing is
much more it than is that atomic point
of consciousness the determinacy of who
I am it is thus the interaction of pure
knowing with itself pure knowing qua
essential being in the universal will
this is something worth dwelling on
notice that Hegel doesn't say pure
knowing or thought thinking itself or
anything like that it has to be
practical it has to include not just
knowing but willing in order for it to
actually be pure knowing related to
itself it has to be pure knowing
involved in action within the world
within determinacy so he goes on and he
says
self-consciousness is there for the pure
knowing of essential being quoi or as
that very pure knowing then he goes on
further as an individual self it is only
the form of the subject or a real action
a form which is known by it as form
again we're getting to the Willing part
through that and here you should start
to see some shades of Conte shouldn't
you the the pure form of the action not
going to say much about that here
because that's going to come up later so
he goes on and he says similarly
similarly objective reality being is for
it's simply a selfless form for that
reality would be something that is not
known but this knowing knows knowing to
be essential being so we come to a new
culture in which we conceive of
ourselves primarily as beings that are
engaged in knowing and willing and all
of us have the same capacities for that
at least ideally as anybody else does
who has transitioned here so we are not
going to slip right back into this old
dynamic of culture we're going to make
in advance
absolute freedom has thus removed the
antithesis between the universal and the
individual will the self alienated
spirit driven to the extreme of its
antithesis in which pure willing and the
agent of that pure willing are still
distinct reduces the antithesis to a
transparent form and therein finds
itself just as the realm of the real
world passes over into the realm of
faith and insight
so does absolute freedom leave its self
destroying reality and pass over into
another land of self conscious spirit
we're in this unreal world freedom has
the value of truth and the thought of
this truth spirit refreshes itself
insofar as it is and remains thought and
knows this being which is enclosed
within self consciousness to be
essential being and its perfection and
completeness there has arisen the new
shape of spirit that of the moral spirit
with paragraph 595 we now come to the
end of absolute freedom and terror which
itself is the last section of this
middle portion of spirit the very long
set of paragraphs and we're ready to
move now into the next section of spirit
which is morality so Hegel is going to
talk about a new shape of consciousness
that has arrived on the scene the moral
spirit and we should dwell a little bit
on how we actually get to this before we
launch into that new section he tells us
that absolute freedom has thus removed
the antithesis the Gagen Zots between
the universal and the individual will
and you know what was the individual
will it could be that of the person who
doesn't have power it can be the person
who's in power the universal or general
will was supposed to be this this thing
that everybody could participate in in
some way and we saw that it took some
some development in order for that to
come to fruition and it didn't come to
fruition ultimately through a new
arrangement of merely social relations
that was what the revolution was
attempting to do but through a new way
of thinking a new way of understanding
itself in relation to human history and
in relation between the individuals and
and and the universal will that is
somehow art being articulated as their
will peer knowing pure willing he goes
on and he says that this self alienated
spirit is driven to the extreme of this
antithesis right and what what else does
he tell us about this antithesis we have
pure willing and the agent of that pure
willing and they're still distinct from
each other now a little bit of a fine
translation but but could be a little
bit misleading we have pure willing you
know Ryan Valen Valen is the
the verb there and is being used to you
know denote the actual willing itself
and then we have the Willer the agent of
willing it's very difficult the same huh
you could translate this better the
thing that's actually engaging in the
the willing at something hein Vohland
right so agent that works but it implies
that like there's something detached
from this this agent or that willing is
merely one of its capacities rather than
what what makes it what it is
be that as it may let's let's go on so
he says that these have been separated
out from each other in this antithesis
and now we want to reduce as he says the
Trant if assists to a transparent form
and they're in the self alienated spirit
finds itself it finds itself this the
spirit that has been separated from
itself the entire time in this entire
section and really the sections before
it is now able to reappropriation is
being overcome it's not being overcome
yet in in reality it's being overcome in
we could say in potential or in ID
allottee and the next section is where
that that is going to it really happen
so Hegel tells us that there's a few
analogies here just as the realm of the
real world passes over into the realm of
faith and inside the realm of the real
world world of culture right passes over
into an ideal world which is also real
in a certain sense it's very akin that
it does in fact do things it does in
fact motivate people it does get them to
do something but it's beyond the real
vehicle eco world that were accustomed
to thinking about similarly there's a
transition here when it comes to
freedom absolute freedom he says
absolute freedom leaves its self
destroying reality the self destroying
reality of the real world that it's
involved in the world of the revolution
the world of the terror the world of
governance and faction and he says it
passes over into another land of self
conscious spirit we're in this unreal
wouldn't if you click you know not
actual you could say world not yet
actual would be better in this unreal
world freedom has he says the value of
truth and we're talking about absolute
freedom here absolute freedom stands you
could say in place of it can be
exchanged for has the value of truth the
truth that we've been seeking this
entire time he goes on and he says in
the thought of this truth not in this
truth but in the thinking about this
truth spirit refreshes itself insofar as
it is and remains thought and knows this
being which is enclosed within self
consciousness to be essential being in
its perfection and completeness now this
is a very rosy picture and you can think
of this as the the outline of where we
want to go of course
as is always the case with Hegel these
great imaginings at the beginning never
turn out to be exactly what we're
working with when we look at it more
closely and try to make it actual but
let's dwell on that for a moment here he
says we've got a new shape of spirit
that of the moral spirit so by leaving
the world in which absolute freedom and
and essentially terror went together
behind and transitioning to a world of
thought in which we can have a pure
willing we now enter a new stage notice
and this is the last thing I'll say
about this that for Hegel this cannot be
jump-started it's not simply something
that you can hand out as a bunch of
acts of people who are stuck in an
earlier dynamic there is a need for
consciousness to work through something
like the French Revolution and the
terror in order to arrive at this point
you